يشارك توت بايبر في اختبار تجريبي
بالولايات المتحده
للقاح لتقليص اورام سرطان الرئه انتشر
السرطان في دماغ توت وهو حريص على
المشاركه في الابحاث التي قد تغير طريقه
علاج المرضى بشكل جذري في المستقبل
ليس لدي ما اخسره وكل ما اكسبه الان سيكون
لي ولاشخاص اخرين في المستقبل كما تعلمون
لا اعرف الكثير عن كيفيه سير البحث
والتجارب ولكن اعتقد ان هذا يمكن ان يكون
شيئا جيدا
بالفعل على اول اللقاحات السرطان الخاصه
به لكي يعمل اللقاح نحتاج الى تعليم
الخلايا التائيه في الجسم للتعرف على
السرطان انه خطير بمجرد التدريب يمكن
للخلايا التائيه السفر الى اي مكان في
الجسم لتعقب الخطر هذه ليست لقاحات
تقليديه تمنع المرض لكنها لقاحات لتقليص
الاورام ومنع سرطان من العوده تخصص
اللقاحات لكل مريض بناء على الطفرات
الجينيه السرطانيه المكتشفه لديه اللقاح
المخصص بهذه الطريقه يدرب الجهاز المناعي
على البحث عن بصمه طفره السرطان وقتل تلك
الخلايا وتقليل حجم الورم لكن مثل هذه
اللقاحات ستكون باهظه الثمن اللقاحات قيده
التطوير في جامعه واشنطن مصممه
للعمل مع العديد من المرضى وليس لمريض
واحد فقط
الاختبارات جاريه في المراحل المبكره
والمتقدمه من سرطان الثدي وسرطان الرئه
وسرطان المبيض وقد تظهر بعض النتائج بحلول
العام المقبل
انني على ثقه تامه بانه خلال السنوات
الخمس الى الثمان المقبله سنحصل على
الموافقه على اكثر من لقاح واحد للسرطان
لاستخدامه في هذا المجال لمنع عوده المرض
قاحه السرطان مثل العلاجات المناعيه
الاخرى تعزز جهاز المناعه للعثور على
الخلايا السرطانيه وقتلها كانت تقدم في
لقاحات العلاج يمثل تحديا فقد تعثرت ابحاث
لقاح سرطان المبكره مع تفوق سرطان على
اجهزه المناعه الضعيفه لدى المرضى
وتجاوزها لكن العلماء يقولون ان الاخفاقات
علمتهم الكثير ايضا ويفهمون الان كيف
يختبئ السرطان من جهاز المناعه في الجسم
مسار جيد في منح المصابين بالداء العضال
فرصه اكبر للشفاء